i am very happy to say that we are
joined
by um the team behind saint maude writer
director
rose ward the stars of the rose glass
sorry rose got
the stars of the film morphed clark and
jennifer ely
and producers andrea cornwall and oliver
castman
welcome um we're also very thankful that
everyone has joined from different
parts of the world while filming so
um yeah we're all on different time
zones at the moment so thank you for
making this happen
in your diaries um i suppose i want to
start from the beginning rose
um as i'm sure most q and a's do
with the conception of the film kind of
where did this idea stem from
um yeah i've still never got a good
concise
interesting answer but you essentially i
think i
i started coming up with like an early
version of what then became saint maude
just as i was finishing
uh film school at the nfts in like 2014.
um
and i just as like an initial premise i
just thought it'd be interesting to set
the story entirely inside a woman's head
and for
her the main relationship within the
film to be between her
and a voice um and quite quickly that
voice became god
and i guess early on i'm sort of
intrigued by the fact that depending on
your personal beliefs and maybe
depending on what era the story was set
in
you could interpret this relationship
either as her
really talking to god or maybe it's some
kind of uh
you know auditory hallucination um
but in a way either either way it's sort
of the same individual experience
for that woman like as a subjective
thing so i just thought it'd be quite
interesting
as an audience member i thought that
would be the kind of film i'd find
intriguing so then it sort of developed
from there i think
you kind of said it's kind of it came to
mind immediately that
the voice would be god and often when
you see kind of possession films it's
often kind of possessed by
the devil rather than god so it's kind
of really unusual take from
the get-go um had it developed further
kind of just being
kind of this internalized storm story
to kind of bringing um kind of the
bringing other characters into it and
bringing kind of the central
relationship
may be shifting a little bit as well
yeah well that's
quite early on in development at first i
thought that you were going to hear the
voice of god and it was going to be a
character and
the whole film would just be her sort of
chatting with this voice in her head but
quite quickly that it's
it started to feel a bit gimmicky and
also as soon as i started wondering more
about
what else was going on in in this
woman's life and who her
you know who the real people in her life
are
that sort of started to seem a lot more
interesting so that quite quickly when
the
amanda character came in and i sort of
realized that the dynamic between
a carer and a patient would be like an
interesting one to exploit alongside
somebody who thinks that they're
saving somebody from god there's just a
lot of sort of weird kind of
power players in it um so i just
thought that would be more interesting
although the voice of god i guess did
make a little appearance back here
um yeah and andrea and oliver i suppose
tony on the page
um the film is really unusual i'm sure
and kind of sets it out apart and sets
it quite differently
as producers coming on board from the
get-go
um what was it a that kind of pulled you
in and totally did you think that would
be quite difficult
to explore cinematically
um no not difficult i mean the tone was
one of the really
intriguing things about it and you know
having seen rose's short films which
kind of ranged from a very
accomplished um uh
short film that she liked film school
and then some more experimental dance
work you could you could completely see
all these
things coming through in a very very
visual sense i i think
certainly you know um
you know as we got very close to
production the conversations were all
about the sort of amount of genre
and that that was the biggest sort of
tonal conversation i remember about you
know is it a horror is it a
psychological film what do we call it
endless debates about psychological
horror or whatever you know and
um you know it's got a very big ending
you know in case if anyone hasn't seen
it i want to spoil it but it it
this character has to go to quite a sort
of deep internal dark
place by the end and just to chart that
and really
feel like you knew her and empathize and
understood that sort of process of
decision making was was the sort of
fascinating thing about how all these
little bits of tone started kind of
ratcheting up
and then kind of talking about their
journey and kind of finding
your lead characters rose howe um kind
of and this is for rose jennifer and
walford how
did the kind of process begin in terms
of the casting process
and then i suppose so centrally hanging
on this
these two in their relationship what was
it that kind of initially thought
that this is the way this is this what
you pictured when you're writing did you
you know have an idea in your head into
that wildly change when it came to the
casting process
um yeah uh
yeah you think when you're writing that
you have like a really
rich full idea of like who these
characters are and you're like oh i've
crafted this thing and blah blah blah
but then
obviously as soon as you start actually
seeing real people and actors sort of
uh performing it and sort of bringing so
much more to it it sort of keeps
constantly changing and and improving
fortunately um
but with i mean with the role of maud i
think we started doing auditions for
that quite early on
because you know finances and everyone
seemed to sort of recognize that
the whole successful failure of the film
pretty much hinged on whether we could
find someone who could pull off this
this role because obviously the
character goes to some really messed up
places and does some really
morally reprehensible things but we've
got to sort of be
with her and sort of enjoy spending time
with her and
i don't know find it anyway all this
stuff um so we started so
for that we started doing a fairly
conventional sort of casting group we
saw a lot of different actors and
more of it sent in a tape i think at
first and then
that was pretty pretty much like phew
we found her this is amazing so yeah no
we just
um pretty much from when came in that
was
that was pretty sorted i don't know how
you found it
um well i just i read the script and i
just really wanted to do it so then i
found the auditions incredibly stressful
because
i um
yeah and i just kind of i remember being
so
my first few auditions i didn't meet
rose and i was like i really want to
meet the person who has this
in her mind and then met rose and kind
of
i felt that we kind of understood each
other and it was actually the same when
i met jennifer i feel there was lots
that didn't have to be said and kind of
between the three of us that just kind
of made sense
and i guess that was kind of sorry which
was when i was just saying that was
fortunate because
um you know we did like i didn't we
didn't really have a huge amount of
rehearsal time any of us like i think me
and more of it had like
a few like a couple of days essentially
we just read through the script and
obviously jennifer came over from
america so i think so and obviously we
cast the two of you and i knew
i was sort of really happy but we'd
never sort of actually
seen the seen you guys together until
pretty much we were doing some
we did like some camera tests i think
sort of a couple of days before we
started the official shoot which was
quite fun
jennifer you had sort of like half of
your bald head makeup done
we're doing costume tests and kind of
half finished set
and uh i don't think we actually read
any scenes it was just i got you guys to
sort of just sit by the bed and sort of
like stroke each other's faces
meaningfully
um but it was kind of reminiscent i
don't remember that
it was like we sort of stole you from
the hair makeup department you you had
your bald head on but none of the sort
of hair bits so you just looked a bit
like an egg
and you had on this kimono which ended
up not using but sort of floating
through the house looking like this sort
of beautiful alien
um i remember it was great i don't
remember the stroking of the meaningful
stroking of faces
i'll have to send you some some screen
grabs or some clips or something
but yeah we all just sort of jumped into
it but it was great these guys
um yeah phenomenal it's really really
pleasant
script when a script is so um it's so
specific and so
um beautifully wrought
and um just creates a world
uh and the the way people speak each
character speaks differently with a
different rhythm and with a different
kind of
you know vernacular and um i think when
something is so specifically um
uh seen and had had written
that um and then is well cast
that you i don't know if you need you
know that's when you can
kind of hit that beautiful spot where
you don't have to talk that much um
and also because there's two characters
who didn't actually know each other
at the beginning of the story so it sort
of makes sense well that also completely
helps yes
yes a little bit of sort of distance and
tension like that's what i wanted anyway
but also could you you were you were
telling the story
you're telling the story you know you
created the story and you're telling the
story rose so you
and you got you got us along to help you
and so
you know we just we just follow that was
one of the wonderful
things about this shoot is everybody
really just
had such faith deservedly so
in rose and in her
the the story she wanted to tell in the
way she wanted to tell it and really
nobody wanted to do anything without
knowing what rose thought about it first
and
if that was what rose wanted and that's
such a great place
to be as a as a group of people
it's very great for me you touched on
jennifer in terms of the kind of the
word
sparse but the the film is beautifully
sparse in
places that you know where i think rose
is
unbelievably this is your feature debut
which is
unbelievable in itself to kind of to you
know
have a complete defeat like this film
which is so
um so sophisticated but the sparseness
would
was there ever a fear to kind of want to
overload it or did you think i need to
get
i need to get things in but you know
there's a nervousness and
quietness and emptiness and allowing
kind of you know working imagine with
your dop with all those little
kind of creeps and like looking peering
through doorways and never
quite getting to the end of the scene
but understanding those moments and was
there ever
the fear to give the order or necessity
you felt to give the audience too much
information
um i'm not sure to be honest i guess
it's always a bit of a
balancing app that you're constantly we
were all sort of discussing back and
forth with each draft of the script and
all this
um but no i mean i
i think maybe i'm sorry i'm answering
this therapy uh
i don't know i didn't i think to be
honest i mean a lot i knew that a lot of
these kind of little moments and the
stuff that
these sort of creeping kind of pauses i
always knew that
i guess that's the sort of world that
the film takes place in like the sort of
stories that i like often
are on the surface i guess quite
contained
simple stories you know physically you
know a few people in a room
but sort of use that to tell quite a so
an intimate sort of small story on one
level but try
to tell it in quite a heightened intense
stylized sort of way
so i don't know my instincts usually to
go really over the top with things i'm
sort of quite
sort of pleasantly surprised that people
are kind of like oh subtlety
um so yeah i don't know
just sort of that's well there was at
some point
you couldn't at the end wasn't there say
it again
there was at one point and dance
sequence at the end so
i thought about it i kept sort of i
think
i started threatening it with like next
thing with developing as well i'm like
gotta get dance routines in everywhere
but i never quite managed it
i mean it's quite it is quite a
ridiculous film i don't know it's kind
of
i mean i like a sort of for me that's
sort of the fun of it
like the tone stuff that you're talking
about earlier is sort of
being sort of big and small at the same
time and serious and silly and
you know sacred and profane and all this
kind of stuff all those contradictions
are
all the most fun thing and i guess with
the characters as well like
um you know part of me was a bit nervous
that both characters potentially could
run the risk of just being a bit sort of
caricaturey or sort of i don't know
um yeah too characteristic or something
but again like then getting to really
sort of
natural very effortless sort of nuance
of performance this kind of
ground needs quite in some way sort of
ridiculous
um characters and scenes because yeah
that's the fun of it i guess
opposites kind of are working kind of
towards
you know both having something
essentially missing but filled by a
thing it's kind of
and when you're saying kind of not to be
one-dimensional
with jennifer's character usually if you
see someone that's kind of
you know in that with their you know
with a terminal and a few kind of not
yeah she'd be retiring gracefully
exactly but she was like
living to the fullest while dying also
maybe living more than most people yeah
like [ __ ]
this is terrible
um we have some questions that have come
through
so uh stephen vogt
is um i suppose this is for andrea and
oliver
he said he wants to talk about genre
versus not being in a genre and how
and how do you sell that to sales agent
does it matter how a film is labelled
um it's an interesting one i mean i
think there's a
there's definitely a bit of a idea that
genre is having a moment
um and uh that
you know everyone should be doing genre
and whatnot and
in some ways i'm a little bit skeptical
about that because i feel like most
actually most films are genre in one way
or another
um especially most popular movies
um there's definitely been a bit of a
kickback against
drama recently and i think there's lots
of reasons for that partly that
the quality of television has become so
high it's very difficult and also the
audience is shrinking
there's just less room for things that
aren't really
you know the big films so i mean i think
we always felt
that we wanted to because saint maude is
very much drama for a good chunk of the
film
um and then it goes it it starts going
more and more wonky
uh into this sort of dark genre space as
uh as it goes on and i
always felt that we wanted to earn
uh the audience's uh
uh price of admission as it were and
and and to go for something that uh
gave them uh some thrills and spills and
some
excitement and something quite unusual
as rose was much more eloquently saying
earlier
um and that was very much part of the
cell we definitely had a
problem in in in what genre did we call
saint walt because you know we knew it
wasn't drama
and we were well is it a horror it's not
you know like the conjuring
or something you know so it was you know
and then we're like is it a chill or a
thriller or a psychological horror
whatever i still don't really know
um i like to think that it's a movie
um uh so yeah a wonky movie
wonky movie multi-genre
genre defying what it is
yes um we have a question from rebecca
clarke um the film has many beautiful
shots and images
um often with no dialogue for example
with um the boiling soup
can you talk about choosing these shots
the importance of their meaning
um well i guess yeah the soups obviously
are sort of
not super subtle um kind of
hint of what's boiling beneath the
surface of moored
so i yeah wherever possible we'd sort of
try and find fun little sort of visual
motifs that sort of we wanted the whole
experience to be very very subjective in
your
even though we we aren't privy to like
exactly what moore's thoughts are do you
want to
sort of sensorially i guess and in terms
of feel we wanted to try and make the
audience
experience more journey as much as
possible
which on the surface like saying it
could be this sort of slightly bleak
thing but what the journey she's going
through as far as she's concerned is
this very important exciting high-stakes
mission with god
and all this exciting stuff so the
visual look of it we wanted
to really bring that out as much as
possible and make it feel very kind of
dynamic and rich and
uh yeah and so there's a lot of kind of
close up this
details i guess just to try and give a
slight more sense of um
tangibleness and visceralness
getting all the words now and textual
and things um and
yeah it's drawing our attention i guess
and we i mean me and ben were very
um thoughts in the dop we worked very
closely together and that was really fun
it was his first feature film as well
and we sort of shot listed every scene
so we were quite organized going in but
whenever possible it's nice to sort of
grab stuff
i think the bubbles the bubbling suit
couldn't pick up yeah quite a lot jumped
in
in the sort of second wave didn't it of
all those little moments because we
we were fortunate we were able to go
back and do another weeks
um not just picking up kind of usual
sorts of things where you just need a
transition shot or whatever but there
was those whole moments that got
scripted and
written in once we had a cut which is a
you know
possible way to work if totally i mean i
know
so i'm veering off from the from the
question a little bit but um
i mean that was honestly like now we've
got to the end of it the ability the
fact that we were able to do that you
know we sort of you know oliver andrea
all
these guys they done you know we had
we had contingency left over we were
able to do a few days sort of pickups
extra shoots
and they that sort of afforded me the
ability to kind of keep writing
extra scenes and beats throughout the
edit with um
mark and it's yeah i mean i don't know
if that's something i'd be afforded
every time but being able to work like
that was just so brilliant because it
mean
you know once you actually are working
with footage in a cut it's
you know it's moved on from whatever it
was in the script and it's kind of
become this other thing and it's i don't
know it was really great to be able to
keep adding to that so yeah like andrea
said a lot of the kind of slightly more
heightened
uh moments particularly we pushed that
as much as we could
in terms of kind of the high times we've
been carrying on from the last question
looking at the aesthetic
of the film it kind of it um has its own
very
specific aesthetic it's kind of maybe
embedded or kind of
uh from other uh other time periods i
think i was wondering kind of
how you put that in place and what your
references were to that
and then leading on to that i'd really
love to talk about the film and the
notion of space and kind of
kind of the confines of the minds of the
characters but also the confines of
space in the house and the town and
so questions in one sorry so the first
question is like the aesthetic in terms
of
production and reference is fine yeah
yeah um
i mean i think before there was never a
script was always the script was always
set in the present day but like in very
early iterations when i first started
talking to
um to these guys about the story i'd
wondered about maybe setting it making
it period film which fell away quite
quickly but
i don't know i mean part of the sort of
retro thing is like
i guess uh slight personal taste coming
through but also i wanted the film to
feel somewhat timeless and unplaceable
because it's not like it's
a story about what it is to be a nurse
in 2019 in scarborough
so we wanted it i don't know
for me i was hoping i kind of find that
films that feel a little bit like
they're set in their own world a little
bit removed from reality it sort of
lends the story that
slightly more allegorical or fable-esque
kind of
feel hopefully so magical
exactly a little bit of that kind of
thing um and season side times are just
really cool and um yeah so
our production designer paulino josko
went to went to town and had a
had a great time making amanda's house
which particularly a lot of that stuff
is and i guess that leads on to the sort
of space
question because yeah we wanted each
physical space in the film to
to again be sort of connected to maud's
uh psychological journey
so amanda's house i think i said to
paulina our designer likes to kind of
not like too literally or anything but
to think of that space a little bit like
a sort of garden of eden gone to seed so
it's sort of a place which has a kind of
sensual sort of intriguing quality to it
but feels a little bit kind of
foreboding so that's why you know lots
of dark shadowy cavernous kind of
rooms and again that makes amanda just
seem that bit more kind of isolated and
lonely and she's just kind of rattling
around in this big empty house by
herself
how you imagined it jennifer from the
script that your house
no was it was it different well i just
i'm curious
rusty like you obviously it wasn't it
was
it was very much how i imagined it oh
yeah
yeah in that sense of timelessness kind
of
specifically also with maud's character
obviously
you have this millennial who is very
kind of who has
um who has millennial today like 2019
2020 tendencies but you also have that
very notion of kind of
someone who is almost rejecting all
kinds of modernity
in a way and kind of that's really it
was in it's like an interesting
dichotomy there's things that are very
very kind of millennial now about her
but also
just manifest in slightly different ways
yeah yeah and one millennial urges
morford how was it kind of playing um
in essence obviously you've got the
voice of god kind of
possessing you but also playing this
millennial at the same time and kind of
having that dichotomy
um yeah i
i when i read the script i was just
terrified of it because i think that
like
maud is my fear of
becoming lonely and isolated through
circumstance or your own design
um and i feel that like the ability to
do that now when we're so super
connected is like
even sadder and i kind of i haven't
really
thought of it like that until there's we
kind of got on set
and jennifer amanda is there on her
iphone and it was like oh my gosh
maude has decided not to be part of that
and that kind of was a big moment for me
because it was kind of
it was i kind of come at it being like
this
this woman's been rejected but without
so much that she's
rejected society as well um
don't know if i'm answering the question
no you are um but um
yeah i found that kind of
it's it's such a fear i think for
people my age to not be connected and to
kind of go for it go for it go for it
that i think
it makes sense for me that you have to
that someone would just
completely take themselves out of it
entirely and i kind of found that
the costume that me and tina and rose
came up with for mort
i felt was really helpful in that
because it was like she was putting on a
costume of another time
where things were purer and better you
came up with that though
oh yeah well because initially me and
so tina calabas um costume designer who
who we're all in love with um
she had made we her and me had sort of
we knew it was going to be a nursing
uniform so yes it would be kind of a
different
sort of persona that maud could put on
but i think we've been looking at kind
of trousers and making her a little bit
more kind of scruffy
and then more and then marvis just came
in kind of saying that you pictured her
in this sort of
more fitted slightly feminine kind of
thing and in a way the sort of fitted
formality of it kind of
adds to the character sort of holding
herself a bit differently and also her
amazing puffer coat which again we and
tina were trying
all these different coats and i was like
maybe it should be a bit film noir and
like a trenchy thing and it just made
her look far too cool
and then one of us was like i've been
picturing one of those puffer jackets
and me and tina just went
ugh not gonna do that and then we put it
on you're like oh that's perfect
um so it's because then it brings you
back to kind of from the constraints of
the uniform
to being in the outside world just being
someone that's maybe in their kind of
very early twenties it kind of brings
you back to yeah what nothing is
essentially
yeah the contrast between the costumes
that she wears as morden then when we
sort of get a glimpse into
into what she's like off duty that was
that was quite fun to work that stuff
out
even at the end there's there was the
kind of it was a sparkly sort of
dressing gown
yeah yeah it goes into for the final
sequence
the saint costume yeah and then it
became this draped sheet
yeah that was all an accident as well
didn't plan any of it really it just
happens
i do want to pick up on that threaded
notion of kind of the idea of
loneliness but i know that we've had a
couple of questions i just want
to give the audience an opportunity so
next year is asking about the seaside
setting
was this always in mind when writing the
script and what was it about scarborough
that attracted
you to it uh yeah it was i think pretty
much always set in a seaside town i'd
initially been picturing hastings
because i was a bit more familiar with
it
um i'm from essex but i've got friends
who from hastings
and i don't know i mean it's it's maybe
a bit obvious but i guess seaside towns
automatically by sort of being at the at
the edge of the land and so the en
and by the sea as the story this adds to
a story
this kind of slightly more elemental
feel and you can
start to read pretentious sort of visual
metaphors into the things which is
always fun
um and also connected to what's saying
earlier about wanting the film to take
place in its own little
universe and to feel a bit timeless
english seaside towns i find
a lot of them you know have this
slightly kind of forgotten quality which
makes sense because they used to be
so sort of glitzy and popular and
glamorous and a lot of them sort of gone
to seed a little bit in a way that i
love like so i think quite early on me
and oliver went and did a
recce sort of around just saw a bunch of
places around the coast and scarborough
just seemed to kind of have a bit of
everything we wanted and it just was
really beautiful and sort of
visually striking place i guess and the
the sea front with all those arcades
that sort of clinched it for us i think
because we
like the fact that you had that this and
just looking over the beach a bit like a
stage
um and then things like that it had all
these wonderful kind
of vertical alleyways which is sort of
we used clothes in the film quite a bit
but you know that was kind of a thing
which we hadn't thought of until we
found the place and it sort of
immediately gives you lots of nice
things of our more descending and
descending and you know we tried to put
stuff
we tried to put her on a hoverboard so
that she could float
through but yeah the alleyways and the
cobblestones made it a bit dangerous
sure the insurance would not have
covered that
um it's really hard yeah until um no
it's just kind of even there is such a
melancholy about
kind of a seaside town that's maybe off
season and it's kind of it gets dark
early in it
yeah we filmed like the week we were
doing all the stuff there like the week
before christmas in 2018 so it was
particularly empty um i
i do think skype is like a really
beautiful place i just like so i always
feel a bit like what kind of game oh
it's just falling apart but
it's a really interesting gorgeous
strange place
i suppose as well on the kind of notion
of loneliness thematically it lends to
that kind of
it being off season perhaps and it being
kind of closing down or shutting down
and kind of that
that theme of kind of um is important
kind of loneliness
alienation melancholy mental health that
kind of that is you know
the crux of a lot of what this is about
as well which i suppose is
was probably so important when you made
it perhaps even more important
today um and kind of just to kind of
what was your relationship to kind of
that part of the script and kind of
making that you know
that decision to kind of make it
part of it what the about loneliness
yeah um well i guess we've all
experienced feeling lonely we're born
alone die alone and all that kind of
and i just think being a human is weird
because we're also kind of
sociable animals in some way and sort of
need connection so much but we all
we're all trapped in our heads
essentially everyone's experience of
reality and life is only ever going to
be experienced to our own little
tiny and you know insignificant sort of
perspective so um
some sort of sidestepping your question
but um yeah
it wasn't really a question anyway
thinking out question um we do have a
question though from robert mitchell who
we're saying
um a moment in the ending seems to
suggest whether maud is truly hidden
voice of god or not
uh rose did you always know in writing
whether maud would genuinely be hearing
the voice of god or not
or for mother when you're playing the
role did you make your own decision
about whether the voice of god
is real or not you go first
okay
i i kind of didn't
think of it as kind of a horror
or um
whether it was real or not because it
was just kind of
the reality ward's reality was
that is god talking to her and it kind
of wasn't until afterwards when i
watched it that i kind of
realized how much of a horror it could
be seen as
um but i i just felt completely like
maude is hearing more is having a
connection with god
like in her mind and that's kind of how
i went with it
and i didn't really i didn't really
question it until i started
what until i watched it and every time i
kind of see it a little differently
particularly with the ending
kind of of like where is she at the end
which i don't like to think
what is that yeah i guess probably the
same for me like when writing it
anything i wrote from
you know trying to think about the
character's perspective on her situation
like already said she unequivocally
thinks that she
absolutely is talking to god and that's
totally like i think an unwavering
uh fairly unwavering sort of perspective
so
that kind of made it easy in a way sort
of that every scene and every decision
she made had to make sense based on that
and then yeah i guess also having an
awareness of how
how you could what you could say is
really going on but it didn't
differentiate it too much i
and i i guess sorry
we didn't really discuss whether no
between us either i think we just kind
of talked about it in terms of her
of her mission and what she thinks god
wants and what she how she thinks
amanda's sort of fitting into all of it
i guess
i guess maybe um in my head i was when i
was trying to work out what
god wants her to do or what how maud's
mission pans out
um it's all sort of motivated whether
subconsciously or
you know for a desire for some kind of
human connection so
for me that's kind of why she latches on
to amanda amanda's the first person and
the agency's expressed interest in her
and seems to as far as more concerned
and seems to
like her and she and that's a good
feeling and she wants more of it and
somehow in her
mind or whether that's really god it
sort of becomes dressed up as this much
bigger grander thing but
try to think about it in quite simple
terms like like that
you almost feel that kind of if they
haven't had um if more than amanda hunt
had
some sort of trauma in their life they
might have actually got on they could
have been
mighty nice exactly you never know
you never know um i found out something
today that blew my mind a little bit
about kind of um
the voice of god within the film which i
didn't realize
um i don't know if you want to reveal
that because that was
very impressed by that
reveal in your deep booming voice
uh god is more of earth speaking and it
is welsh
because more of it is welsh
yeah i like this aspect of it because
i'm kind of went to welsh language
school but don't really speak it that
much anymore
um but all
i've i didn't go to church or anything
despite coming from
on one side quite religious family and
the only time that i
did any prayers was in school and so it
kind of made her
so welsh to me that the i that god her
only
time she would have ever spoken to god
as a child would have been in welsh
and it kind of makes it even more kind
of secret and special for her
yeah and that was bad well that was one
of the nice things about what i was
saying earlier about being able to sort
of keep
keep writing and um throughout the edit
because that scene where
where god talks to maude wasn't in the
original shooting script but during the
edit you know we did some things around
and it was you know i sort of realized
that it felt that we needed
her to have one sort of final kind of
confrontation with with god where maybe
she's doubting a bit and he sort of
pushes her over the edge so then we had
the fantastic of imagining
what form god would take and how god
would sound
and obviously by that point i'd um you
know got to know more with doing the
shooting and heard
in her speaking welsh to you know sister
on the phone
so i had a nice and some thought what a
lovely sounding language that nobody's
going to recognize
and and obviously it has the nice sort
of circularity of it then being in
in her head so so that was that was it
was fun to work like that because the
character wasn't written as having to be
welsh or anything that's just
in terms of kind of the character kind
of um were
when you were writing more than amanda
were you writing to them from the place
from kind of the seaside town that you
were imagining or were you always
writing them as outsiders to that world
um i'm trying to remember
and no initially amanda was english i
don't think either of them were ever
like from the town but amanda was
initially at least you know from
england um and that became sort of the
main
thing of that character sort of slotting
into place was when we
decided on jennifer for the casting and
the fact of
the idea of her being from a different
country just
even just the simplicity of that sort of
already adds so much more ambiguity to
kind of where this character's come from
and why she's ended up sort of running
away
gives their character more of a sense of
kind of hiding um
and yeah more of it being it was nice i
i think i don't know i sort of didn't
think about it too much i think we were
fairly open with in terms of where the
characters could be from through
geographically
ish um i think
yeah and did they change at all kind of
so with jennifer and morpha did your
characters kind of
once you kind of came on board and met
and met rose how did kind of
did any of it like this story develop
even further were there bits that you
brought that perhaps weren't there
beforehand
um i don't know if i understand the
question
oh no okay so i'm saying that kind of
well and you came on board kind of
things that perhaps not might not have
been in the script but by you coming on
board to take on amanda's role with a
certain little things or certain
idiosyncrasies that you brought
to the character loads
i don't know bought herself
i would say what was what was oh sorry
i can't tell i'm talking across canoes
um
i would say what i found was great that
jennifer isn't it and jennifer is
american is that there's kind of
more constantly getting stuff wrong and
not getting things
and misreading stuff and there is a
directness
in to americans that we don't have as
much in britain
so there was kind of i felt with maud
that
there was it was kind of relaxing to be
around someone
who was so to the point and kind of
there wasn't a guessing game around her
as much as maybe with other people
and um and also the kind of
the the lines in jennifer's accent in
jennifer's voice just sounded so much
more
of poetic and magical and i was kind of
like mord would be like wow
yeah there's that weird thing of like
brits just automatically being like wow
americans
amazing yeah
i mean there's an early draft where
amanda was
much more um you know she's an older
person
and i think you know with you jennifer
you know just
suddenly it was someone who was
you know a dancer but much more
glamorous and there's this whole
question about is is maude slightly
jealous
or turned on by amanda's relationship
with her girlfriend and that that sort
of sense of somebody whose life is still
very much
it made her whole situation and illness
more sort of
awful and tragic as well it's not again
like you were
very like you were saying at the
beginning it's not like a sort of
slightly
usual thing of having maybe some older
frail lady sort of
gracefully retiring and receding it's
kind of like this this woman who's like
in the middle of quite of you know
really exciting
full kind of life with a lot of autonomy
and then sort of it's all kind of
yeah so i don't know that seems more
angry
yeah a life that perhaps moored could
wouldn't even kind of even be able to
achieve with everything with still being
so full of life
and how yeah yeah exactly and then she's
got this young
exactly um we have another question
um rose were there any particular films
you drew upon to inspire your creative
vision
oh yes i just realized you asked me that
earlier as well and i didn't answer it
um
yeah i mean of course like you're
constantly sort of
other things floating around in your
head um
i mean in terms of some of the style and
tone and stuff i always end up
listening with the same things but lots
of kind of early polanski films and
bergman for some of this like very
claustrophobic uh
pressure cooker psychodrama kind of feel
and
kind of slightly weird twisted humor and
then films like um
taxi driver was always one that we kind
of discussed
in development and early on that was
quite a useful
way of getting some development execs to
sort of try and get where we were coming
from with the character kind of
imagining like if more
if travis bickle was like a young
catholic woman living in an english
seaside town
um and this sort of yeah the sort of the
unhingedness of that character and how
differently they see themselves compared
to how everyone else sees them
um and then i don't know but mixed bag
of things like for some i
love that you know like sort of slightly
campy over-the-top kind of stuff so like
even
the devils by ken russell for some of
the sort of really
you know ludicrous melodrama
theatricality and and the
performances in that are so kind of big
i guess
and uh whatever happened to baby jane
and
um forgetting things now a bunch of
stuff the servant
that was that was a useful one in terms
of like films starting off quite kind of
formal and
austere and then sort of gradually by
the end descending into this very
weird warped stylized kind of place
next stuff from everywhere i suppose the
one thing i haven't touched on
is obviously the film was supposed to be
theatrically released
um in april but then a little thing
called the global pandemic came and
threw us all off kilter but it did get a
theatrical release
in the uk just in the last few months
which is it's been super successful
and um which is fantastic and i'm
wondering kind of maybe oliver andre i
don't know if you want to talk about
kind of other global releases or if it's
kind of we'll be showing theatrically
again hopefully
and where else in the world might you be
able to see it on the big screen
yeah i mean it's a little bit early to
say i mean obviously
you know we we made a whole bunch of
plans which got upturned
um so yeah we'll be able to sort of
announce the us
plans soonish but you know obviously the
you know things are still
very much in the middle of it all over
there so we've just
had to move our french release which was
supposed to be this week or next week or
something
so which you know-ish yeah so that fact
moved forward so yes i mean it's
you know the film sold worldwide so we
premiered at toronto
and yeah it got it got picked up
studio canal had it here um a24 in the
u.s
dear whanau in france sony western world
so and
yeah and and some places i think oliver
you
sent around the spanish language trailer
earlier tonight oh yeah we've seen you
both dubbed
more yes from jennifer yeah great
i'm speaking spanish how do they do the
god beetle is that still welsh
i assume so oh yeah
short answer is yeah we very much hope
so but i mean obviously things are out
of our hands on
when cinemas are going to be opening up
globally and you know you know we're
just pleased that we're connecting with
audiences
and i think i think it's true i think
there is sort of layers that are coming
out
because of where we all are now in terms
of our
isolation and loneliness and some of the
thematic material is
is really speaking to people at the
moment
yeah definitely kind of you know people
kind of especially with obviously
moored's kind of hearing kind of voice
of god but other people kind of having
their other
other obsessions or other um
mental health manifestations um
we um i just want to say thank you so
much for joining us back to q a
congratulations on and an astonishing
piece of
cinema um i do hope that people get to
see it on the big screen again
um if they haven't already um and thank
you from
from all corners of the world thank you
for hosting it thanks for watching
anybody and thanks for waking up early
more of it
[Music]
so